what's poppin rockstars my name is mt
and doesn't it feel like just yesterday
we were witnessing aircraft carriers get
absolutely
wrecked by a giant pissed off
radioactive dinosaur
and the streets of tokyo get absolutely
stomped on by a giant gorilla in
godzilla vs kong
like those fight scenes were insane man
it's crazy dope
especially when mechagodzilla jumped
into the ring unannounced to make reptar
and mojo jojo work for it which of
course has left me with a feeling
of burning jealousy ever since like why
couldn't it have been me
lord like why wasn't i the one to
experience what it was like to get
jumped by a godzilla on an aircraft
carrier while giving my boy king kong a
lift huh
why not me like that little girl gia
from the movie
had it all what a lucky duck
but thankfully pubg mobile knows what is
good in this world because their new
titan strikes event
captures that same exact vibe while
providing players worldwide with some
pretty cool skins let's take a look gang
then we got the godzilla set i'm i'll
dig that suit so much and we got a
mechagodzilla set
do we we do we have a skin that looks
like mechagodzilla we do
have a skin that looks like mega
godzilla and it looks
amazing oh i just i just love the back
the back is where it's what makes it i
don't know why i like the backs of these
suits i just like the way the
the back scales look because like those
red jagged scales
make it look like um you know you'll get
a little hurt
touching touching those you know what
i'm saying okay here we go
the carrier oh the godzilla rep
we got the kong rep it's about to go
down
fight fight fight fight fight fight
fight
fight fight enter player 3
mecca godzilla oh wait oh
shoot oh we got the atomic
fire weaponry are you kidding me the gun
glows
too and this is all on a mobile game
yo that's sick look that oh my god that
suit looks tight
that suit looks tight and the gun looks
tight oh my god
like back in the day back when i was you
know playing video games on console like
as a kid
like that those were the types of
graphics that we were getting so like
now that we could do
this on our phones what
what oh
wait that's red wait why is that red
something is wrong that's a red oh wait
no that's mega godzilla
oh here it go oh
carrier didn't have a chance not one
chance
oh you gotta watch out for that tail wow
that looks impressive
that oh and here he is wow
are you kidding me mobile games have
evolved
to a different level intercept shoot
oh my god this is so fun oh i would love
to just grab a couple of friends and do
this
like this is so much fun this looks like
crazy fun
all from your phone really oh now we
find them from the sky
all right i guess you could take down
the aircraft carrier we don't need that
no more oh my god mechagodzilla looks so
good and we got the thunder and
lightning in the background
wow so oh here comes the og
he heard you was stealing his whole flow
and here comes
the monkey himself oh my god just like
the movie
using the axe oh my god
that's what i'm talking about that's me
and kong we homies
oh we got a minigun
shoot him shoot him
power it up got him
now you're armless and now you're
headless probably
yep definitely headless right on the
aircraft carrier
primo spot for a mechagodzilla head
gotta say he got him he said
fight me and godzilla was like oh cool
it's over
bye
hey man oh my god that was so freaking
cool
wow that was kind of crazy man like pub
g has definitely been evolving over the
years because when pub g first started
it did not
have awesome stuff like that like wow
holy cow like this event looks like it's
going to be a crazy fun time especially
if you're looking to
you know take down a massive robot kaiju
with some buddies on your phone the pub
g mobile really did it because
i feel like it really does capture that
you know
i'm a small man watching giant gods
fight in front of my face type feeling
which is you know something that i've
always wanted
and thankfully pubg mobile is always
updating with new and fun events so be
sure to download the game and check it
out using the link below
to
on twitter or download else like
instagram but most importantly just
please make sure to follow new rockstars
on youtube
and make sure to hit that notification
bell so you can get notifications
whenever we upload
new videos
[Music]
you